In a previous video, we walked through
the steps for creating a single dot.
Let's go one step further
and explore adding rows of dots.
First, let's think of this stitch
pattern as a series of units.
In this example,
each unit consists of a single row
plus a dot in contrasting color.
The contrasting color is represented by
both light and dark blue in this diagram.
Gray are stitches that are not knit.
Remember, we're working short
rows and partial knitting.
And white in this diagram
is the main color.
This entire gray section represents
a single row of knitting.
The dots are seven stitches,
an odd number, and there are eleven
stitches, an odd number between the dots.
The rows of dots are
separated by the main color.
In this example, it's 10 rows
shown in white on the diagram.
To make this stitch pattern interesting,
the dots are alternated on the next row.
I've started by casting on and knitting 10
rows in the main color,
ending with the carriage on the right.
Remove the main yarn and put it aside.
We'll pick it up again.
The next steps will create
a single row of knitting.
Keep that in mind.
I
plan to position the first dot five
stitches from the edge,
and then repeat dot units across the row
with 11 stitches between each dot.
So I'll count five plus seven needles,
and then put the rest of the needles
on the needle bed in hold.
Set the carriage to hold.
Thread the carriage
with the contrasting yarn.
Knit across these 12 stitches and wrap.
Now I want to concentrate
on forming the dot.
I'll put those first five needles in hold
position and put two more needles
in hold opposite the carriage.
There are five needles in work.
Knit to the right and wrap.
Notice I'm adding a claw
weight in that dot section.
Opposite the carriage, put two needles in
hold and there are three needles in work.
Knit across and wrap.
Opposite the carriage,
put one needle in hold.
There are two needles in work,
knit across and wrap.
That completes the dot.
Let's look at working the next unit.
We'll put the two held dot needles
on the left into work.
There should be four needles in work,
plus put 11 needles for your spacer,
plus seven needles for the next
dot into working position.
So you'll have a total of 22 needles.
The needles to the left are
future dots and remain in hold.
Still working with the contrasting yarn,
knit across these 22 needles and wrap.
The carriage will be on the left.
Now, count seven needles in work
next to the working yarn.
This is our new dot.
We'll isolate that second dot by putting
all needles but those seven into hold.
Start forming the second dot by putting
two needles opposite the carriage
into hold. Knit across and wrap.
Opposite the carriage,
put two needles in hold.
Now there are three needles in work.
Knit across and wrap.
Opposite the carriage,
put one needle in hold.
And there are two needles left in work.
Knit across and wrap.
That finishes the second dot.
Your carriage should be on the right.
Prepare for the third dot by putting
needles into work as before
following your diagram.
Again, there should be
a total of 22 needles in work.
The needles to the left are future dots,
and they remain in hold.
Still working with the contrasting yarn,
knit across these 22 needles and wrap.
When the last dot of this first row is
complete,
put all needles in hold position,
cut the contrasting yarn,
and free pass to pick up the main
color yarn, and then knit 10 rows.
We're ready to start the next dot row.
Remove the main yarn from the feeder
and set the carriage to hold.
We want the new dots to be
positioned between the previous dots.
According to my chart, I'll have 14
stitches plus 7 for the first unit.
Put all needles except
these 21 stitches in hold.
Thread up the contrasting yarn
and knit across these 21 stitches.
Now, identify the seven dot needles
and put the others in hold,
and then start forming your dot.
Opposite the carriage,
put two more needles in hold.
There'll be five needles in work.
Knit right and wrap.
Opposite the carriage,
put two more needles in hold.
There are three needles in work.
Knit left and wrap.
Opposite the carriage,
put one needle in hold.
There are now two needles in work.
Knit right and wrap.
As before, put two dot needles back
into work, plus needles for the next unit.
Which is 11 plus 7.
Knit across and wrap.
Short row as before,
forming the second dot.
Continue working the units across
the row to complete this second dot row.
When the last dot is complete,
cut the contrasting yarn,
free pass to pick up the main
color, and knit 10 rows.
Alternating the dots adds
interest to your knitting.
The best way to master the stitch pattern
is to learn to do one unit and then
think in terms of units across the row.
It's best to work out your
stitch pattern on graph paper.
Be sure to use odd numbers for the dots
and odd numbers of needles
for the stitches in between.
One more thing to consider,
you don't want to create bobbles
by adding too many rows in the dots.
This photo was taken before blocking,
and you can see the raised dots.
So take care as to how many rows
of the dots you're knitting
for a single row of this stitch pattern.